[Musique]
c'est logique que tu doives choisir
euh de ce côté le côté via ukraine si je
puis dire parce que nous faisons partie de l'otan
et nous voulons faire partie de l'
union européenne à un moment donné j'espère
euh
mais d'un autre côté nous nous
est-ce que
nous aimons vraiment les russes,
généralement les monténégrins aiment
les russes
et dépendent d'eux plus qu'ils ne les aiment
bien sûr, c'est de notre faute
si nous n'étions peut-être pas si
autorisés quand nous expliquons au monde
qu'il est dangereux
[Musique]
depuis le  euh le monténégro est devenu
dépendant depuis 2006 pour disons 2010
lorsque nous avons eu cet investissement dans la construction
euh dans le boom immobilier que la majorité
de l'argent qui a été investi dans la
zone côtière provenait de la russie
donc fondamentalement nous n'avons pas de liste claire
mais il y a  des rumeurs selon lesquelles de nombreux
oligarques, bien sûr, non pas en leur nom,
mais au nom de différentes
sociétés offshore, ont des biens au monténégro
[Musique]
la guerre s'est produite
et nous devrons détourner notre attention
vers d'autres marchés
et aussi je veux dire j'essaie toujours de  être vous
savez
optimiste et dire qu'il y a je veux dire une
doublure argentée dans chaque nuage
peut-être qu'il est grand temps pour nous d'essayer de
diversifier l'économie
peut-être qu'il est grand temps pour nous, vous savez
juste de ne pas dépendre d'une seule
branche de l'industrie à savoir le tourisme
[Musique]
vous